hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John old M Humphrey you know what
I'm not afraid of what Greg racism on me
too I welcome it I if it's define you to
directly attacking me ward me
I don't welcome it upon others tweet me
being a white guy you gotta be ready I
am Not Afraid of spoilers why cold crash
pitchers one of our top reward tiers on
patreon is whatever video you requesting
most definitely I'm trying to make sure
we're both centered so when we do the
crop ends its equal whatever reward tier
you want on patreon you can be this one
basically whatever video request is
definitely don't put up on YouTube we're
gonna do why I'm not afraid of spoilers
let's do this so today I'm gonna talk
about something that came up a lot in
the last couple of years on my blog
namely why I'm not afraid of spoilers
generally I prefer to go into a film not
being spoiled but even if it is I
usually don't mind that much in fact
sometimes I actively seek out spoilers
you must be now film bought it I'll make
a video of baby need spoilers without
anything so I will warn you right now I
am going to spoil the following two
films which one this video I saw one of
those I've seen a lot of smoke so what
is this boiler a spoiler is telling
somebody what to expect from a movie
before you go see it
which means lets you see it let's take
this sick sense as an example if I told
you that Bruce Willis actually died in
the opening scene and he's been haunting
Haley Joel Osment for the whole film
you'd no doubt consider that a spoiler
but what if all I told you is that the
ending is bittersweet what if all I told
you is that it's a supernatural thriller
with a romantic subplot what if all I
told you was that it's a Shyamalan film
an early Shyamalan film at what point
does last information about the film go
from just information about the film to
a full bull and spoiler don't we all
want at least some form of spoiling
before we go see a film I'm talking
about something as basic as knowing what
your Shondra it is because genre is a
spoiler a mild spoiler but a spoiler
nonetheless when we say romantic comedy
neo-noir
historical drama huh it puts a series of
expectations in her head so it's not
exactly giving away the ending but it is
a form of cluing us in to the content of
the film speaking of giving away the
ending back in the olden days no the
real olden days there were only two
genres comedy and tragedy and back then
comedy didn't mean funny haha
why else would they call Dante's Inferno
the first act of a Divine Comedy as
opposed to tragedy which meant exactly
what it means today which is way more
information on modern reviewers tend to
want to reveal when they toil or is gone
it's gotten so bad because it's think
revenge should be a principal you look
at the back of the movie box and if it
isn't filled with just the vaguest of
vagaries written by some publicist and
the bowels of the Marvel Studios
mailroom at best they might finish
summarizing the first act for you and if
the first act ends with any sort of
surprise anymore full of intrigue they
stop right there and you have no idea
what to expect from the rest of the film
except for whatever it's John
redesignate might suggest I like knowing
how a film was gonna make me feel before
I go see it that's why I think we should
bring back the whole comedy tragedy
designation or at least not shy away
from it like it's the plague going still
further not only do I not mind knowing
how the film is gonna make me feel
oftentimes I like knowing how will the
film expects to make me feel that way
which is where full-on plot summaries
come in if I'm particularly interested
in knowing why Moviefone calm thinks the
barrel ride sequence and the desolation
of smaug is going to blow my mind I will
read a full plot summary on Wikipedia
and see if I agree here's why I think
people have a
all right we've got reaction to avoiding
spoilers at all costs the reason is
because you can only watch a film for
the first time once and people want the
viewing to be special and for a lot of
people what makes it special is not
knowing what comes next
I know people like that they'll see a
film once and then they can never see it
again
and it's fine this isn't a video about
why everybody should spoil films for
themselves this is just a video about
why I don't always mind them and if you
want to see some pretty remarkable
thoughts that aren't my own on this
subject go read the Wikipedia page which
explains why they don't use spoiler
alerts on any of their articles and on a
more personal soapbox you note I believe
that reading detailed plot summaries
before you go see a film can spare you
from watching a lot of crappy movies
there's a problem in Hollywood which I'm
sure I'll go into in a future video but
it basically boils down to this movies
are expensive they cost a lot to make
and producers want as much of a
guaranteed return on their investments
as they can get so they hire multiple
writers to tinker with a film's plot
with the logic that hey experts are
better than one and five are better than
two
but movie scripts aren't built by focus
groups they're built by artisans and
multiple competing visions can easily
spoil a film that's that's why you got
so many blockbusters these days which
seem to pull themselves in so many
different directions and water
themselves down with a lack of focus or
they let their imaginations sit in the
front step never coming up with anything
that hasn't worked for some previous
film nothing new nothing exciting
Wow or in that rare film that's come
along the one that neva Tabo way that's
never been done in quite the same way
before the film that secretly been
building to an inexorable but logical
reveal without cheapening or and
validating what came before it those are
the kinds of films I don't want spoiled
for me I got that ones but everything
else
those self-aware twist endings that are
just gunning for a twist for twists sake
no need to waste anyone's time
people love that twist long story short
I care more about how a thumb was gonna
make me feel on the 50th viewing rather
than the first
[Music]
[Applause]
look opinions are subjective mm-hmm
until I have yeah it's an opinion piece
he stated his opinion that be he's wrong
like entirely yeah I hate this man and I
hope that misfortunes befall him for the
rest of his life
this guy cuz we disagree and that's what
you do hit the dislike button here yeah
and I'm gonna find his address and on a
mailing some hate mail go [ __ ] yourself
you stupid no-good idiot of a person you
know I actually make some pretty good
points maybe if he replies back to me
with some kindness I might change my
mind because that's a true sense of
character oh yeah if he replies like I'm
a normal human being I will backpedal
it's hard yeah possible yeah and I will
respond with oh whoa I wasn't actually
expecting a reply but now that you did
I'm sorry I'm just having a bad day man
I saw your video first thing on my bad
day I just had to say some thing about
viewing experiences they're not oh
they're not all the same he has some
solid points
I guess arguably I would care more about
how a film was gonna make me go off his
last thing here I would care more about
how films gonna make me feel in the 50th
time as opposed to the first time but
damn do I care about that first time I
care a lot about that first time like
Annie personally I hate spoilers I hate
swoosh I think sometimes people get a
little ridiculous about oh you know
what's the spoiler
Eimer for our Finity war movie review we
both said like black panther is kind of
underutilized you're certainly focusing
on him a lot when he pops up but doing
less things than when you pop in on this
everybody else sounds like there's no
spoiler doesn't yeah it's like it's not
something that you can look at the movie
and like automatically decode if it's
part of the trailer is selling you on
they go to Wakanda Black Panthers in it
and I give you a heads up that hey he's
not in this movie a lot black panther
too
you know I feel like you might actually
get a more rewarding experience because
you're not expecting Black Panther to be
in there for a lot of the film yeah I
come down in a weird way on this one
because I get where he's coming from
coming from coming from and I do agree
that yeah we should be thinking about
what the 50th viewing will be like
because now more than ever I feel like
movies have become so much bigger and
more extravagant and yet somehow more
disposable because given is just that
now there will always be another one
waiting if this one does well and it's
already in the works and the only way
it's not gonna happen is if this goes
catastrophic ly bad
I do appreciate what he's saying here
and I feel like that's a theory that I
would maybe meet him halfway on it best
for those movies where I'm like I'm on
the fence about this I could go either
way about actually seeing it but if I
read the plot breakdown and it turns out
that I'm very fascinated I might go but
if it's a movie I care about I don't
want to add just those things distract
me if it's like I know there's a plot
point coming up I'm gonna sit there with
it in my mind you know yeah yeah we all
want some form of spoiling as he says
like that's what his trailer is we I
think what he calls some form of
spoiling is just a hint you know like
here's a vague idea of the experience
you might have and I have yeah I agree
with that well especially for the big
films they always tease the finales the
[ __ ] big shot of Avengers when the
sort of like circling around yeah I'm
like that's like my favorite shots the
major tracking shot was going all around
the battle but the big posing shot
probably all worked and that's also
something too because I feel like I
would feel differently towards a big
blockbuster that I know is gonna follow
certain major beats versus something
more off the beaten path that could take
a sharp left turn something with it was
like The Sixth Sense it's like I
wouldn't want to know that going in
because surprise is an element I think
that is important to certain movies and
I appreciate for most all movies yeah
this is this line here we said it two
different ways of better implying the
same thing he's like I'm like you know
like how a film was gonna make me feel
before I go see it or I like knowing
how will the film expects to make me
feel that way and how is two very
different statements though yeah because
no matter what no one can tell you how
this movie's gonna make you feel yeah
they expect you to feel that one makes a
lot more sense to me in terms of
marketing opinions Rotten Tomatoes being
factored in all those elements and for
me I like generally I do like that like
I feel like a trailer is good enough for
me if I really don't want anything
spoiled I might just see the Rotten
Tomatoes consensus the blurb capsule
yeah anything I would just see the
tomato meter her and go whoa whoa
spider-man in the spider is looking
pretty good the 6% Wow but yeah I didn't
actually read any of that because I just
want to see what this move is all about
everyone's loving it so much drive was
the same thing I didn't read anything on
Drive and I didn't see a trailer drive
was the opposite experience I didn't see
a trailer but I saw Rotten Tomatoes saw
how high of a score was he kept saying
stuff like cool art house action stuff
sounds cool check it out and then I
ended up loving it ultimately I don't
think because he has a point too about
what is being spoiled the laid runner
2049 got spoiled for me minutes before
we watch watching the movie I was still
able to really enjoy it I was bothered
by the fact that reveals were given to
me right before I was really like
annoyed about the Hat yeah and so
occasionally pull me out knowing what
the ultimate reveal is this is building
up to that but so many films are about
journey
it's true a lot of times I have these
films that hidden John plot-twists might
not be as effective the second time you
watch it because oh wow this film hinge
so much on that twist yeah thanks so
much on that reveal that's not even that
enjoyable of a journey and depending on
your genre - it's like tension comes
from mysteries so if you just read the
whole movie it's up to the tone now to
do all of the tension yeah basically I
get why some people wouldn't have a hard
time you know reading a plot summary and
just going into a movie and enjoying it
and I've seen things where I've had
endings spoiled or moments that are huge
spoiled that have still been effective
or that when I watched the episode or
the movie I didn't see the moment coming
in the moment but but at the same time I
don't share this approach in an opinion
you know I'm not talking about a movie
called Moulin Rouge you guys can skip
ahead if you want to David Seaman Rouge
yeah before I saw Moulin Rouge I was
told Nicole Kidman dies before I saw it
and then the person I forgot who told me
but the person says they see it in the
beginning she dies whatever I watched
the movie I know she's gonna die
beginning movie if I know she's died
he's gonna die and then before she dies
I'm going it's like the mark of a great
prequel mmm when you like well I know
how this is gonna pan out yeah but I
don't want it to you know true that it's
like a prequel in an in it of itself
it's technically filled with spoilers
too because of the fact that it's a
prequel because we know that at least
these people won't die and they'll
demonstrating like you get a fantastic
beast - situation where they infuse new
plot elements or like wait a minute what
it's kind of based on the Lord not every
time a spoiler will ruin a movie and
sometimes but the thing is going back to
whatever I really start talking about
every viewing experience is different
here sometimes it won't be a bother and
then other times it's gonna be a real
bother you know like to know that for me
I don't know for me just taking in those
things it's hard not to think about them
so for my mind as a movie goer I know
the more details I put into it
beforehand the less I'm just gonna be in
the moment watching the movie and that's
important
a movie based on a true story you could
look up the true story and if a movie's
accurate to the story you know what's
gonna happen yeah yeah yeah there are so
many ways to approach the argument of
spoilers when you have so many different
genres that hinge on so many different
things and there are movies that are
formulaic to a point where the point is
not that they're going to defy the
formula and so in those cases I'm like
sure whatever I could probably guess
them yeah but it's about how they
communicate the plot and I like the way
he touched on that idea too that it's
how it wants to make you feel and then
you know by reading the plot you see how
it's going to do that you know how it
wants to achieve that feeling for you
thank you
free context we're watching a movie I
appreciate as point of view and I and I
think he did a good job articulating it
I just don't share it very I don't know
that level of viewing experience because
for me it's like my viewing experience
kind of the opposite of everything
because the thing is is like I don't
think ultimately spoilers should
deteriorating to watch this movie I
already know what happened like I I hate
I personally hate that sounds like I
know the ending it doesn't matter I'm
not gonna watch it if it's a good movie
yeah you should just there's always so
much more to that there's a lot more
work than just one plot point you know
always you know experience always but I
also think that the filmmakers generally
want you to just watch it with little to
no knowledge yeah it's that way it's all
fresh I think about like if the artists
the creators all the countless people
whether it's the artists or the focus
groups you put this bad boy together
they're gonna want you to really
experience it the proper way which is
little to no spoilers I think what I
appreciate most about this though is
that the title is called why I'm not
afraid of spoilers and I feel like
spoilers have become this very
contentious very angsty topic because
you know a we've all had a moment where
somebody's spoiled something in a show
or movie we care about and it does make
you mad if you cared I do feel like
there are certain ways in which we could
you know defuse some of that anger
through at least some of this
perspective you know even if I don't
fully agree with him I like this guy
uh-huh I do yeah I'm gonna delete that
comment it's a good opinion please yeah
you know what I'm pulling back
nah I've seen the screen all the
keystroke command after a second I was
like okay let's no type so hard Kurt
Anderson is the guy who requested this
Kurt are nomads friend who I don't
understand how he has a cellular device
when he's Hawking Road converters man
burgers I think I asked him once like
where does your money come from and I
don't remember because this guy's as
always traveling for for leisure like
supernatural he's just got kasi and
fraudulent credit cookies like he's
never done business trips he's traveling
for leisure across the world back track
in the world right now maybe hey maybe
he just rolls up in a town you know gets
a little part-time gig you know like
sleeps some plays low maintenance I mean
I've seen a cystogram guys in shape he
looks great chiseled I know he's a sexy
man or a sexy man Kurt a not afraid no
spoilers thanks for sharing us this
video and thanks for sharing to us and
thanks for introducing us to this
channel man appreciate it that's not
serving this liver for giving us the
shirt he's a man you guys can't
subscribe to the reject nation
interesting this magic 8-ball that you
might have heard me annoyingly playing
around with here well it's my Rubik key
Oh John there's no time you didn't
prepare click that notification bill
gosh you frustrated me check us on
patreon we got a lot of goodies over
there where it's all about bonding and
love and kindness I hate having to be
fake around
[Laughter]